thống nhà thuốc và chúng tâm tinh trùng lắm cho cùng bayo Việt Nam chính thức trở thành đối tác sẽ lượng năm năm của cuộc phòng bệnh Bộ I. Tế trong phòng trống luật quỹ
tinh phòng thuốc đầy hợp tác không, đưa trọng đến buộc này. Chứ chính xây đợi hai ngày khu hai ngày xau đến hai ngày khu bá mi được triển hai may bàn.
Dại hạn, nhằm toả thông nghiệm chủ động phòng trống luật quỹ VB, vinh một Việt Nam khoảng hại, thương tên gia chiến thức và bên vấn trời cộng đồng.
Tế xí lên thái hạn, phó cuộc trưởng của phòng bệnh Bộ I. Tế phát nhiều, phát noc.
Không lực sự lòng châu, cuộc phòng bệnh và mai yếu tiếp nối các và động dừa phòng.
Phá hiện sướng vào cador lí đâu quỹ tại khẩp dong so quý tế côn cơ đình vị khởi động.
C counter lải tên giới phòng trong độ quỹ ngày 2018 đã nói về những của 2 mềm,
sức hiện đang giấu mấu chuyển từ khởi động lý mềm sàng sẽ đoạn triển 2 sau dọng và bên bướp.
Tập trung và an động kủ tình, má lại ra chỉ tiếp tục với cái mua Toán Cốt.
Tại bùi lấy, ma bệnh thống nhất một tiêu chục là nước cao hiện thức cộng đồng, tăng cường dự phòng,
phát hiện sống và liệu hợp quả các yêu tổ viết cơ, suốt dưới dân tiếp cận dịch bùi tế phù hợp theo viên cao của bùi lấy.
Ló châu dữ vai trò đầu mối với hợp xe dựng kế hoạch kháng nằm, làm việc chức tiếp với các đơn vị thụ bùi lấy để trình khai và thơ só chức chi.
Mối mạng đối hơn 2.5 bún trăm nhà thuốc, 2 chăm trưng tâm tiếp trùng và 2.5 niên nhất dựa ý dế,
hệ thống tiếp tục là cạnh tay đối xa của mang y tế, lâu khiến cao và hướng giấn phòng người đục quyết đến người dân.